[Applause]
i remember the first time we got on a
start line
and it's just adrenaline blood was
pumping heart rate was racing
being on a sidecar does add the extra
dimension because you've got to work
with the person next to you
having him as my brother in the sidecar
is what it's all about
i'm sam halton i'm andy houghton we're
brothers and we're a competitive sidecar
across team
i started racing probably when i was
about 10.
um i'd been on a bike since four years
old ah there you go that's a mean look
isn't it
i was
maybe 13 in that picture
sam beat me once in the last race that
we had no yeah yeah yeah yeah
still only ever beating me once yeah
won my first championship with the local
club about 11 or 12 years old rover bike
all the way up through different
championships to i was 24 in 2005 and
that's when i had my accident
[Music]
i had an accident while i was out
training
i ended up going over the handlebars and
and landing flat on my back
shattered my t7 vertebrae
that one moment kind of changed my life
i came out of hospital and i spent a
couple of years without without doing
much
it's only so long that you can fend off
that desire and that bug to get back on
a bike we found the sidecar and now i'm
out racing this thing which is fantastic
when i tell people that i race sidecar
they seem to assume that i'm going to be
the one in the passenger side but
that's not the case um i'm on the bike
the guys in the side card there's no
sitting there's no sitting at all
they're throwing themselves from left to
right and you've got to be fully
able-bodied
my role on the team is effectively to
turn the bike in to keep it level to do
that it's a case of chucking your weight
from side to side
if andrew wants to go one way and i'm
not on the same wavelength we're not
going that way
most of the time he knows what i'm going
to do as brothers you've probably got
that that relationship a little bit
closer than you would otherwise
[Music]
that feeling you get when you're out on
the track
for me it's what i live for
you get it banked into a corner and
you've got the bike drifting sideways
i'm out there and no one knows that i'm
in a wheelchair no one knows
you're just one of the guys you're a
sidecar racer you're not a disabled guy
and it's just it's an amazing feeling
[Music]
it's something that you feel a
connection with people automatically i
don't think there's a better feeling you
can kind of move the night with the
music and the energy of the people can
also move me
it just really feels fulfilling
[Music]
hi i'm angel i'm dren
we're twin djs and producers
what makes a good dj is being observant
if i play one track and i'm just like
everybody really responded to that it's
going in your head in a split second
i've got 10 other checks that sound just
like that
we do switch off usually every 30
minutes
she can kind of like move off of what i
did
when we're not playing we're watching
the audience she'll be playing and i'll
come over and wrestle up and like play
that next i know when my twin has it
we'll be okay
we we've been the bra grew up in the
bronx new york and it's a really
jamaican area a lot of reggae playing
out in the streets all the time
in fifth grade we entered this program
that helps inner-city
youth that are generally underprivileged
we got very lucky but some kids don't
get as lucky we got through middle
school and high school and we got into
dartmouth and we both decided to go
there
so when we graduated we came back to the
city
i was playing with equipment on and off
i went home one day and i told her like
this is what we have to do
after you graduate from college nobody's
thinking you'll then go on to become a
d-day
it was one of those moments where you
had to be resolute in what you were
doing
there's no kick yet
[Music]
and then the bass hits i kind of like it
i think dj is definitely a predominantly
male industry
we've heard some negativity from
not even other djs but people and
audiences and i think it's been
surprising just because it doesn't feel
like djing should be a gendered thing i
take a burden upon myself to perform
better because
we are women we do get a lot of good
feedback from girls and women who want
to learn a deal who want to learn how to
dj
if someone told me that i would end up
being a professional dj with angel i
would not have believed it
when you follow what you like and you
follow your dreams it can take you
anywhere
[Music]
in southern pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the american civil war this is
a story about that place
it's also a story about cats
thousands and thousands of little cats
[Music]
this is rebecca hi i'm rebecca and this
is her twin sister ruth hi i'm ruth and
we run a museum of dioramas that are
made with handmade civil war cats civil
war
cats the combination of a childhood love
for clay cats and a strong fascination
with the american civil war it started
out as a hobby that we just did as kids
putting around in our bedrooms
that bit of child's play led to a
full-fledged museum which opened in
2013.
[Music]
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because
they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale one eighth of an inch equals one
foot in cat feet and so each one of our
soldiers represents one soldier who
would have been on the field we'll
calculate the numbers that would have
been left in the regiment and we'll fill
it in with that many cats soldiers so
for example low around top we're going
to eventually have about 5 thousand
soldiers on it typically one like the
angle we figure took us about four and a
half years the little round top diorama
we figure is more of a five or six year
diorama
we really just want to make the civil
war more approachable i guess for people
so they can relate to the history and
have more of a connection with the men
and the women involved
now that the word of this cat museum is
out all the people who love cats come in
and now not only are they seeing our
dioramas of falling in love with the
five and a half thousand little furry
smiles smiling at them
but they're also learning the stories
and suddenly they have an appreciation
of gettysburg and the history just
because they came to see the cats
[Music]
when my little brother lucas was born my
parents were told that he wouldn't walk
or talk and the doctors even said he
might not make it to his 10th birthday
but today a few months away from his
10th birthday we're doing our 15th
triathlon together
my name is noah aldrich and this is my
brother lucas aldrich
lucas
hey guys i'm talking
[Music]
noah is 11 and lucas is nine and lucas
was born with a rare genetic neurologic
condition called listencephaly
he's unable to walk unable to talk he's
unable to feed himself but despite all
of his challenges he's the happiest
little boy that you'll ever meet
about four years ago our boys started
doing triathlons together and most cases
that wouldn't be a big deal a lot of
kids do triathlons but there's something
very special about the way our boys do
triathlons
[Music]
i pull lucas in a raft for the swim
portion
then i pull him in a bike cart during
the bike
and i push him in a running cart during
the run
i wanted to do this because lucas can't
do things like we can he can't really
play sports so this is something we
could do together
currently we're training for our 15th
triathlon which is this weekend
before the race i always feel nervous i
don't think i'll ever get over that i
just don't want to hurt lucas i don't
care if i win the race he just has to be
okay
[Music]
before the race lucas gets serious and
he gets his race face on and they're
ready to compete
[Music]
they swim around 200 yards
then they transition to a bike
they'll go usually about three to five
miles
and then they'll run about a mile
noah is strong physically and especially
mentally because he's truly only doing
these races for his brother
sometimes i feel like that it's gotta be
over soon right but i just hear lucas
that's how he says go faster
every day is precious with that little
boy
i try to soak in the experience because
we don't know how long the boys will be
able to do triathlons together any one
of them could be their last
what these boys accomplish gives me a
nice sense of pride
noah lucas for an inspiration people see
these two young boys and it gives them
hope and it gives them encouragement to
go out and tackle life challenges
[Music]
you